foreign
Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez step out
marking their first public appearance
since tying the knot it's a beautiful
moment the newlyweds were all smiles on
Thursday at the Ralph Lauren spring
summer 2023 runway show in Los Angeles
cuddling up holding hands and posing for
the cameras the two rocked head to toe
black Jen in a wide-brimmed hat
full-length pinstripe dress with
matching clutch then in a suit shirt and
tie let me do our best the triple threat
stopped to talk to women's wear daily
about the three custom Ralph Lauren
dresses she wore on her wedding day and
her man he was right by her side thank
you so much
and inside the duo held hands front row
as they sat in between fellow a-listers
Diane Keaton and Jessica Chastain
back in July the two tied the knot in an
intimate Las Vegas ceremony and one
month later they exchanged vows in front
of friends and family in a lavish
Georgia wedding I can tell you it was an
honor it was absolutely beautiful and
I'm gonna let them share more but it was
truly special it was beautiful to
celebrate love last month E.T chatted
with author and life coach Jay Shetty
who officiated the couple's ideas I met
Jennifer a couple of years ago and she's
just been absolutely phenomenal we've
collaborated a bunch of times and I got
to meet Ben through the process is
wonderful of course Jen and Ben
reignited their flame 17 years after
they called off their engagement in
2004. it was my first kind of heartbreak
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak it was like
a tough one for me and when E.T caught
up with Ben's longtime friend Kevin
Smith just days after he attended their
Georgia nuptials he got emotional
reflecting on the couple's special day I
was absolutely beautiful you know she's
got impeccable taste so the whole
wedding looks fantastic
beautifully appointed Flawless but he's
never been happier I've seen that dude
be happy but the pure joy that was like
radiating from his face it was
absolutely Unforgettable it is honestly
one of the like 10 sweetest uh precious
most precious moments I've ever
witnessed in my life and it wasn't even
mine uh I was happy for him man they
were happy you could tell like they
worked hard to get here they earned it
and it was so nice
[Music]
thank you